[Musique]
jamais un face-à-face présidentielle
dans l'histoire de la vème république
n'aura été aussi tendu un match de boxe
pour reprendre les termes de la presse
italienne un show à l'américaine
agressif selon le new york times si le
débat entre les onze candidats avait été
saluée comme une réussite démocratique
le débat d'hier soir entre emmanuel
macron et marine le pen a surpris par sa
virulence et ce dès les premières
minutes serge cimino xavier de pertes
ce débat c'est avant tout l'histoire
d'une candidate pressé d'en découdre
on s'attendait à un débat programme
contre programme mais la première
intervention de marine le pen donne le
ton
de libéralisation de la précarité de la
brutalité sociale de la guerre de tous
contre tous celui qu'elle appelle alors
l'enfant chéri du système un peu
bousculé par ces dernières jboss talent
vous avez démontré que vous n'êtes en
tout cas pas la candidate de l'esprit de
finesse de la volonté d'un débat
démocratique équilibré ouvert merci pour
cette belle démonstration que vous venez
de faire madame le pen de deux heures
trente de débat tendu avec cet exemple à
la clé autour de la question du
terrorisme
non seulement vous n'avez pas de projet
mais en plus vous avez une complaisance
pour le fondamentalisme islamiste il
faut évidemment fermer les mosquées
salafistes il faut expulser les
prêcheurs de haine je serai intraitable
et je mènerai la lutte sur tous les
plans contre le terrorisme islamiste
mais ce qu'ils attendent le piège qui
nous tendent c'est celui que vous portez
c'est la guerre civile c'est là que la
différence politique c'est le ton
général de ce rendez-vous d'entre deux
tours qui retient l'attention qui
pourrait peser dimanche prochain dans ce
débat qui a été marquée par une violence
verbale extrêmement forte il peut y
avoir éventuellement un effet soit de
remobilisation
certains électeurs indécis ou tentés par
l'abstention se disant non là vraiment
on ne peut pas faire comme si de rien
n'était soit un effet qui pourrait être
plutôt un peu plus favorable pour
emmanuel macron dans les urnes demain en
tout cas l'image ce dernier échange ils
ont été assez souvent loin du projet
contre projet vous êtes à plat ventre en
permanence devant l'allemagne devant le
syndicat dame nature van liew iec devant
les communautaristes lui de donner
puissances d'argent entre différents les
banques à plat ventre et madame le pen
dit dame rappelé avant je suis debout
mais pour être debout je n'ai pas besoin
de salir ma permanence vous salissez
représenter les étrangers vous salissez
les juges comme on vient de le voir vous
salissez les uns et les autres madame le
pen notre pays n'a pas besoin de ça il a
besoin d'apaisement et d'efficacité une
tonalité qui rappelle à cette
journaliste américaine la campagne de
donald trump chaque fois qu'on a entendu
un débat ces derniers ces dernières
semaines on voit du fact checking le
lendemain dans les journaux français
donc donc le
ce changement de de fond parce que c'est
pas seulement la forme qu'on a vu aux
états unis se semble se poursuivre en
france et c'est marine le pen qui qui en
a la plus grande responsabilité
[Musique]